لكن هل ستدافع القوات الأمريكية عن الجزيرة ،
نعم إذا كان هناك هجوم غير
مسبوق
[موسيقى]
ما الذي يجب أن
يعرفه الرئيس الصيني الحادي عشر بشأن
التزامك بتايوان نتفق مع ما وقعنا
عليه منذ فترة طويلة وأن هناك
سياسة واحدة تجاه الصين وتايوان
يصدرون أحكامهم الخاصة بشأن استقلالهم ،
نحن لا نتحرك ، فنحن لا نشجع
أو نكون مستقلين ، ولا ندع
هذا قرارهم ، لذلك على عكس أوكرانيا
لتوضيح الأمر يا سيدي ، فإن الرجال
والنساء الأمريكيين سيدافعون عن تايوان في
حالة الغزو الصيني  نعم
أجنبي سيدي الرئيس ما ستقوله له
إذا كان يفكر في استخدام
أسلحة نووية كيميائية أو تكتيكية لا
يغير وجه الحرب
على عكس أي شيء آخر منذ الحرب العالمية الثانية.
أوكرانيا من خلال هناك
المساعدة الكبيرة التي نقدمها نحن وحلفاؤنا
والشجاعة المذهلة ،
فإن التصميم المذهل
للشعب الأوكراني لا يخسر الحرب
ويحققون مكاسب في مناطق معينة من
الفوز بالحرب في أوكرانيا هو
الحصول على روس.  سيا خارج أوكرانيا
يعترف تمامًا بالسيادة ،
شكرًا
لك على هزيمتهم لروسيا ، تبين أن روسيا
ليست مؤهلة
وقادرة كما يعتقد الكثير من الناس أنهم سيكونون